there's always something a little
poignant about the end of something
maybe that's what people get drunk on
New Year's Eve to forget it it's sad to
think that a whole year is over but if
you think New Year's is depressing how
would you feel if you thought that all
life on this planet was ending soon 3
million years of human history erased
forever sad isn't it Chris Hayes think
so Chris Hayes is what every man would
be if feminists ever achieved absolute
power in this country apologetic
bespectacled and deeply deeply concerned
about global warming and the patriarchal
systems that caused it on Friday Hayes
hosted a town hall offense on MSNBC with
congresswoman Alexandria Kazuya Cortes
it was designed to promote her green New
Deal this apparently seemed like a wise
idea to executives over at NBC the very
same news outlet that's been 2 years
lying to about Russia
brings you a 29 year-old former
bartender to teach you about science
Hayes frame the terms at the outset of
the show unless you do exactly what dr.
Acacio Cortez says the entire human race
has only 12 years to live what we have
to do to avoid the most catastrophic
effects of climate change is to cut
emissions in half in 12 years 12 years
that's the project we've been tasked
with by the earth has come a bold new
policy proposal that might be the most
controversial thing in American politics
at the moment you've probably heard
about it it's called the green New Deal
some people call it a socialist monster
some people call it our only hope for
survival here in the way of life that we
hold dear it looks like Ellen kind of a
fusion show but did you hear what he
said our only hope for survival holy
smokes that is terrifying help us Chris
Hayes where is this life raft this
humanity saving antidote that alone can
prevent the death of our children well
the good news is that Alexandria Kazuya
Cortez has the cure for human extinction
all we have to do is obey her
and be very very good people in my
framework in my belief that we not just
have a wealthy society but that we have
a moral Society wait a second you may be
wondering how does a member of Congress
who hasn't yet turned thirty someone
who's never even raised children get the
right to lecture me about morality well
that's the difference between you and
Alexandria Kazuya Cortez she is a highly
decent person listen to her explain how
she doesn't resort to ad hominem attacks
unlike her enemies who by the way are
xenophobic white supremacists we're
actually talking about something
substantive we're not calling anyone
names people say Tea Party of the left
and I find this phrase very interesting
this phrasing very interesting because
the grounding of the Tea Party was
xenophobia the underpinnings of white
supremacy yeah stop with the
name-calling you racist white
supremacist xenophobe so it's official
Alexandria Kazuya Cortez is a [ __ ] and
nasty and more self-righteous than any
televangelist who ever preached a sermon
on cable access she's not impressed and
she's awful so how does she get so
famous why do people like her well for
being honest we got to say it's because
not everything she says is wrong listen
to this clip it's from the same town
hall a Kazuya Cortez takes a break from
radiata climate theology to offer what
turns out to be a fairly insightful
critique of the American economy
we have runaway income inequality we are
at one of our most in equal points
economically speaking in American
history we are dealing with the crisis
of how our economy is even made up our
economy is increasingly financialized
which means we are making profits off of
interest off of leasing your phone off
of doing all of these things but we
aren't producing and we are an
innovative innovating in the way that we
need to as an economy okay
you hate to admit it given the source
but try to ignore the way she said it
maybe just print it out and read it a
lot of it's basically
true now their party wants to talk about
this the Republicans are in fetal
position they just don't want to be
unpopular anymore they'll do anything
not to be unpopular the Democrats want
what they've always wanted total and
complete control over you and this
country neither party will say that our
economy at its core is badly distorted
any economy based on interest payments
isn't really an economy it's a scam
healthy countries innovate they make
things they don't treat people like
interchangeable widgets they don't
worship finance in a healthy country
bankers aren't heroes private equity is
not the highest-paid profession nobody
brags about working at a hedge fund in
America right now we have the opposite
unfortunately and that's why Alexandria
Kazi Cortes has a constituency not
because she's impressive she's not but
because she's one of the very few people
who will say the obvious about growing
corporate tyranny in this country
doesn't mean she's right about anything
else taking power from the banks in
giving it to a Kazi or Cortes as she
proposes would not solve our problems
it'll just put an even dumber person in
charge but she's right about the
financialization part